merci de ce premier ce premier
témoignage maintenant demander aux
agriculteurs de venir et donc alors
présidente christiane christiane lambert
on a un petit jingle non on fait tout ça
en direct
oui alors voilà
bien alors j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
christiane lambert
d'abord vous allez voir ce soir il ya un
peu une petite reconstitution ang lee de
10 août puisque vous allez voir cette
tribune les trois anciens présidents de
des jeunes agriculteurs qui se sont
succédé de 90 à 98 mais au-delà de cela
au delà de ce passage de la présidence
du cnj à christiane est d'abord
agricultrice en maine-et-loire sur une
exploitation polyculture et en élevage
porcin
c'est ça son métier elle et c'est la
particularité du syndicalisme agricole
c'est à dire qu on est engagé pleinement
dans son métier et on représente les les
agriculteurs donc je vais laisser
christiane vous adressez nous adresser
quelques mots peut-être de réaction
d'abord sur certaines propositions qu'on
a pu faire ou tout simplement sur ce que
le témoignage qu'elle a envie de porter
et puis ensuite on a comme on le fait à
chacune de nos conventions nos amis
parlementaires
on aura deux députés enfin deux députés
nationaux une députée européenne eaa
sénateurs qui vont qui vont nous
rejoindre et puis qui à la fois
interrogeront ans christiane mais se
feront aussi le relais de questions
d'internautes puisque vous êtes toujours
très nombreux à nous suivre
christiane voilà je te laisse la parole
qui ne donne combien de temps on va dire
aller 7 8 minutes
quand on fait des questions réponses ok
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup aux
christian bonjour à toutes et à tous oui
un certain nombre de visages connus ici
et puis d'autres peut-être au-delà
puisqu'il y à la retransmission
merci pour votre invitation pour parler
d'un sujet qui m'est cher le sujet de la
vie mais après il ya d'autres vies et je
voudrais aussi dire combien c'est
important qu'on puisse maintenant
évoquer ces sujets là pourquoi nous
sommes dans une année extrêmement
particulière delà du fait qu'on peut pas
manger ni boire au restaurant et ça je
vous rejoins guy c'est vraiment
extrêmement triste et ça affecte le
moral de beaucoup de gens ça affecte
aussi de budgets de nos viticulteurs
brasseur etc etc
les français ont re découvert
cette crise ou grâce à cette crise
l'importance de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
ceux qui pensaient que nos rayonnages à
l'aide toujours pleins ceux qui
pensaient que il pouvait y avoir aucun
risque de pénurie se sont tout d'un coup
mis à faire des réserves de produits
stockables puisse 360 pâte plus de 150 %
de sucre puis 145 farid la semaine
raconte finement comme si la disette
allait revenir et que l'inquiétude les
gagner et ils ont réussi en fait à
remplir leurs placards et leur frigo
parce que l'agriculture et la chaîne
alimentaire dans son ensemble c'est à
toute la chaîne alimentaire qui est
producteur jusqu'à la caissière de
supermarché en passant pour te par toute
la logistique la transformation et
salariés l'abattoir si souvent décrit
avant et tout ce qui a assuré cette
logistique plus tout le grand écosystème
agricole les vétérinaires les ingénieurs
qualité tous ceux qui ont été au rendez
vous parfois sans masque et sans gel on
était là et ont répondu présent et c'est
assez gratifiant pour nous de voir qu'il
ya cette reconnaissance aujourd'hui mais
c'est assez surprenant de voir qu'ils ne
l'avaient pas vu auparavant
voilà des années que nous et poumon 'non
à dire attention danger
la photo est encore belle mais la vidéo
se dégrade
parce que l'agriculture est en train de
régresser je vois ici le sénateur du
bloc en a fait un rapport sénatorial et
qu'il a pointé
chiffres en main nous avons eu de cesse
et rappelez vous le livre de mon
prédécesseur xavier beulin fin 2016
début 2017
l'agriculture est en danger ce qu'il
faut faire et est le sous titrage
donc voilà des années que nous disons
attention si nous continuons sur cette
voie là nous allons être importateur net
dans quelques temps et donc les français
confiné en télétravail en cuisine et en
re découvert les plaisirs de la cuisine
et l'importance de l'alimentation
il ya eu aussi des mots on aime pourtant
prononcé la souveraineté alimentaire
alors c'est un mot que beaucoup de nos
collègues meilleures fêtes de collègues
que beaucoup de nos amis ne mesurait pas
la souveraineté qu'est ce que ça veut
dire mais aujourd'hui on voit par
exemple que des chaînes de construction
automobile sont arrêtés parce qu'il nous
manque les composants électroniques qui
sont fabriqués à 75 % en asie est en
cours à 75 % à taïwan donc ça veut dire
que la capacité à nourrir sa population
en toutes circonstances même en période
de crise
quelque chose de précieux et que
l'agriculture et l'europe globalement a
réussi à le faire alors si nous avons
réussi à le faire et parce que nous
avons milité et beaucoup ici l'ont fait
avant moi pour des politiques agricoles
à la fois nationales et européennes qui
ont permis de construire une agriculture
compétitive résiliente et de plus en
plus durable résiliente elle l'a été
mais nous avons aussi vu un certain
temps de fragilité fragilité sur un
certain nombre d'approvisionnement
fragilité sur la main d'oeuvre
disponible pour faire un certain nombre
de travaux dans nos exploitations
agricoles notamment les travailleurs
saisonniers
il a fallu déployer beaucoup
d'imagination pour trouver les personnes
pour travailler dans nos exploitations
nous ne les avons pas tout trouvé et
nous avons dû faire appel mais ses
chroniques à de la main d'oeuvre
étrangère
alors ce moment a été particulier pour
les agriculteurs parce que nous n'avons
pas arrêté de travailler
et comme la victoire aime travailler se
sont sentis plus reconnu il a eu des
signes de reconnaissance de la part des
présidents de régions de départements de
la part du gouvernement en direction du
monde agricole dans son ensemble les
industries agroalimentaires pour dire
vous avez tenu bon c'est bien continuer
à tenir bon
nous nous en avons profité entre
guillemets pour dire attention
maintenant que tout le monde parle du
monde après écoute et les agriculteurs
et les acteurs du grand secteur agricole
vous parlez du monde après et de ce
qu'il faut faire pour tenir et ça
rejoint beaucoup de propositions que
j'ai vu dans le document que vous nous
avez transmis et puisque tout le monde
écrivait sur le monde d'après je vois
qu'il ya eu 17 propositions pour le
monde après dont certaines d'ailleurs
qui ont déjà disparu
la fnsea a écrit un manifeste pour une
souveraineté alimentaire solidaire parce
que nous considérons que c'est une bonne
horizon un manifeste qui associe
l'ensemble de la société produire
l'alimentation ces nobles mais si la
société n'est pas au rendez-vous et
cherche toujours des produits peu chers
et bien ce sera plutôt des produits
importés alors que si la société qui
passe une commande qualitative de
produits premium plus de qualité plus
environnement plus du bien-être animal
moins d'antibiotiques tout ce que nous
faisons au fur et à mesure parce qu'on a
toujours su s'adapter et on saura le
faire encore demain et bien produire en
france à un prix
quand on achète un véhicule français ou
un costume français ou des chaussures
françaises
on sait qu'on le paye plus cher que ce
qui vient d'ailleurs
de provenances plus exotique mais
produire en france à un prix mais ça
permet aussi de relocaliser de localiser
de garder en france un certain nombre de
productions qui sont essentiels pour le
territoire qui font la noblesse de la
france de la gastronomie à la française
qui occupe aussi tous les territoires il
n'y a pas de territoires abandonnés ou
en friche et en france les zones de
montagne ont été accompagnés en son
temps et le sont encore parce qu'il y
avait des difficultés spécifiques c'est
la politique agricole commune et c'est
aussi une déclinaison sans sac française
que jacques chirac a très bien porté en
son temps donc l'agricultural est
capable de répondre à tous ces enjeux-là
et de s'adapter énormément et j'ajoute
que si nous avons rajouté le mot
solidaire c'est parce que pour nous ce
n'est pas une approche ferme et c'est
pas l'autarcie en disant produisons chez
nous point barre comme certains le
préconisent aujourd'hui en disant mais
pourquoi produire tout ça puisque après
tout les français ont besoin que 280 bon
sens de ce que vous produisez nous
savons que l' équilibre dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises qu'il s'agisse du
sucre et on l'a beaucoup dit l'année
dernière au moment du débat sur les
néonicotinoïdes pour conserver nos
sucreries françaises ont besoin à la
fois du débouchage des rieurs et de
bouche export pour trouver l'équilibré
dans leur entreprise nous savons que
c'est la même chose matière porcine si
on n'a pas la chine et d'autres
destinations pour absorber les oreilles
les v6 et un certain nombre de produits
gras issus de nos ports n'atteint pas
les équilibres matière et on peut dire
la même chose y compris pour les
produits laitiers qui ce sont deux ans
plus de plus en plus commercialisé
certes en très bon fromage noble mais
aussi en ingrédients prisé par certains
et les chinois pour la poudre sont ont
débouché extrêmement précieux donc nous
sommes dans une approche d'agriculture
ouverte mais pour commercer pour jouer
dans le commerce international nous
avons besoin de règles équitables ils
malheureusement elles ne le sont pas
tout on voit que il y a de plus en plus
en france et en europe des règles qui
vont crescendo au coût du travail des
règles sociales sanitaires
environnementales qui génère des coûts
supplémentaires mais si les frontières
sont pas soirée laisse rentrer des
produits qui ne respectent absolument
pas les mêmes règles
ce qui malheureusement trop souvent le
cas et bien nos agriculteurs font
faillite et
les secteurs qui ont le plus souffert et
qui ont le plus mis la clé sous la porte
en france sont les secteurs les plus
employeurs de main-d'oeuvre horticulture
pépinière maraîchage arboriculture
quand nous étions ensemble au cmj at-il
souvient dehors bruno darnaud nous
produisions 400 mille tonnes de pêches
et nectarines nous consommions 400 mille
tonnes de pêches et nectarines
aujourd'hui en france nous ne produisons
plus que 200 mille tonnes de pêches et
nectarines nous en mangeons toujours 400
milles on en importe 200000 espagne
portugal italie
elle arrive plutôt moins cher et elles
font le prix directeur qui tire vers le
bas les prix des productions françaises
quand en plus on a le coût de la main
d'oeuvre que vous connaissez si on n'a
pas le maintien d'un théaux 2e et je
vois que c'est dans vos propositions
eh bien nous n'arriverons pas à tenir
ses productions l'a donc parler de
souveraineté alimentaire sépare les
donnes tout cohérent à la fois des
politiques nationales ambitieuses pour
garder aussi des moyens de production en
france quand on parle d'innovation quand
on parle d'irrigation dans les
présidences sont des gros mots qui
heurtent trop d'oreilles or on ne fera
pas demain l'agriculture si on n'a pas
des moyens pour répondre aux enjeux
nouveaux notamment les enjeux
climatiques qui sont devant nous et qui
sont conséquents l'agriculture est une
activité d'extérieur de grand air
57 % du territoire est occupé par le
production agricole 30% par la forêt si
on ajoute ces deux secteurs nous
occupons 87 % du territoire dont nous
sommes les premières victimes du
changement climatique nous le subissons
nous avons notre part de responsabilité
aussi dans les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre notamment sont troisième
secteur émetteur mais nous sommes aussi
un secteur de solutions plus que
d'autres plus que d'autres et c'est
ainsi qu'il faut revendiquer alors à la
fnsea nous avons pris ce sujet à bras le
corps loin des critiques classique
disant que la fnsea ne regarde pas ces
questions là nous avons écrit l'année
dernière un rapport d'orientation qui
s'intitule faire du défi climatique une
opportunité pour l'agriculture qui est
un petit peu notre feuille de route pour
les trois ans qui viennent
où nous faisons un constat sans
concession des éléments changement
climatique de l'impact qu'il ya sur nos
activités d'extérieur de culture mais
aussi sur l'élevage sur les modes de
consommation des français et donc sur la
nécessité d'avoir à la fois des nouveaux
outils pour faire face
l'irrigation la sélection variétale la
génomique
bref tout ce qui nous permet d'être plus
performants l'agriculture de précision
tout ce qui nous permet de vraiment
d'être en phase pour répondre mais c'est
aussi des outils assurantiels qui nous
manque aujourd'hui qu'ils ne font
cruellement défaut et sollicite en
l'état nous avons pour l'instant des
refus d'accompagner alors que c'est un
facteur de résilience extrêmement
important et d'autres pays l'ont compris
pas plus loin que l'espagne à notre sud
qui a mis en place un dispositif très
intéressant de couverture de gestion des
risques que nous nous n'arrivons pas
encore à mettre en place
alors c'est aussi l'enseignement la
formation pour accompagner les
agriculteurs l'enseignement agricole
joue un rôle énorme dans notre pays sous
tutelle du ministère de l'agriculture et
nous souhaitons garder
nous avons la chance d'avoir des
pépinières de jeunes dans ces écoles à
tous les niveaux dans les maisons
familiales dans les lycées agricoles
dans les écoles d'ingénieurs plus de
filles que de garçons aujourd'hui parce
que ce sont des métiers de création des
médias tracts if les métiers du vivant
et nous avons un enjeu de renouvellement
extraordinairement important en plus du
défi climatique nous avons 46 % des
agriculteurs qui ont plus de 55 ans et
qui vont donc quitter dans les six ans
qui viennent
et si nous n'arrivons pas à réinsuffler
des discours plus positif des messages
plus positif une lisibilité par rapport
aux politiques conduites et bien nous
n'encourageons pas les jeunes à
s'installer
ce qui caractérise beaucoup d'autres
pays quand même c'est l'instabilité et
la volatilité des cours certes mais
aussi des règlementations les sur
transposition qui ont été la règle
pendant longtemps mais qui ont grévé
aussi notre compétitivité et qui ont
conduit à ce que nous constatons dans
les chiffres
quand on était aussi un lieu encore on
avait 14 milliard d'euros d'excédent
dans la balance commerciale on est
descendu à 6 moyenne sur les quatre cinq
dernières années et nous sommes
aujourd'hui challenger sur les grandes
cultures par exemple là où nous étions
exportateurs en russie et ailleurs
la russie est devenu un concurrent y
compris dans le bassin méditerranéen
cette géopolitique du blé elle est
extrêmement préoccupante
ce qui nous appellent donc reconsidérer
la nécessité absolue d'être à la fois
dans leur montée en gamme que l'on sait
faire mais aussi dans la compétitivité
pour beaucoup de secteurs y compris les
secteurs des bouchers intérieure pendant
les états généraux de l'alimentation
qu'on était un grand espoir pour les
agriculteurs il était beaucoup question
de monter en gamme probablement trop et
trop exclusivement nous sommes gros
importateur de
un d'entrée de gamme de vins d'entrée de
gamme parce qu'il ya un public pour
cette consommation de viande d'entrée de
gamme
parce qu'il ya un public pour cette
consommation et je crois qu'il faut
regarder avec objectivité pragmatisme
tous les modes de consommation tous les
moments de consommation et nous
agriculteurs français nous voulons être
capables de produire pour tous ces
moments de production donc c'est pour
moi un enjeu capital
moi j'ai beaucoup d'espoir dans la jeune
génération qui arrive aujourd'hui dans
la tente qui la nôtre aujourd'hui nous
sommes un métier attendu c'est important
d'être attendu il ya des métiers dont on
entend moins que le métier d'agriculteur
et l'ensemble de la filière agricole
agroalimentaire et tout l'écosystème
mais pour cela il faudra peut-être
écouter davantage les spécialistes du
sujet les experts les scientifiques et
pas toujours le bruit de la rue où le
bruit d'un certain nombre de groupes de
pression qui ont parfois conduit à des
décisions
idéaliste mais qui rue des conséquences
économiques et sociales dramatiques pour
l'agriculture dans un certain nombre de
régions donc c'est le moment de choix
important il y à la réforme de la pac
qui arrive en débat aujourd'hui c'est
pour les 7 ans qui viennent nous sommes
préoccupés par un certain nombre de lois
qu'on par exemple la loi convention
climat ou la loi climat et résilience
qui arrivent nous craignons des sur
transposition encore nous aurons besoin
de la vigilance de chacun d'entre vous
là où vous êtes
pour éviter d'en sur ajouter sur la
barque france qui a pu ré encore un
petit peu plus notre compétitivité donc
portant la voix des graines agriculteurs
je dirais que la souveraineté
alimentaire et solidaire que nous
portons elle est vraiment france et
europe
les consommateurs ont re découvert
l'agriculture qu'ils nous restent
fidèles et nous pourrons ainsi à nouveau
tracé des bottillons d'horizon pour
notre agriculture et pour tous les
agriculteurs qui ont vraiment besoin de
retour de confiance en l'avenir merci
merci merci christiane d'abord pour ceux
ce témoignage de d'espoir parce que
c'est aussi une particularité une
spécificité du syndicalisme agricole
c'est d'être au delà de des
revendications nécessaire mais c'est
d'être porteur d'espoir et de favoriser
l'arrivée à la fois de jeunes
agriculteurs est hors cadre familial tu
expliquer
le succès dans les écoles d'agriculture
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'on est
effectivement sur un métier qui ouvre de
formidables perspectives et il faut le
dire le répéter c'est une contribution
j'irai à l'effort de la nation c'est une
contribution une présence sur sur le
marché international et puis tout
simplement c'est des emplois directs et
puis c'est les paysages auxquels faisait
référence
guy savoy il ya quelques ya quelques
instants ses paysages ils sont ce qu'ils
sont parce qu'il ya des agriculteurs qui
travaillent et qui est qui façonnent
ainsi nos paysages par l'activité
économique alors deux premières
questions pour christiane christiane
quel regard portez vous sur les ailes
les nouvelles applications dont je
parlais justement précédemment qui
remplace de plus en plus l'étiquetage
traditionnelle dans les foyers français
vous savez mon iphone smartphone scanne
un produit est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle respecte toujours le savoir
faire nos aux agriculteurs et c'est une
question de frédéric de nice merci
est-ce qu'il marche mais malheureusement
non certain nombre de ces applications
se sont mises en place de façon très
dynamique et aujourd'hui elles ont
beaucoup d'utilisateurs
malheureusement un certain nombre de
nutritionnistes regrette aujourd'hui
alors c'est difficile de donner un nom
et d'un accusé une puisque les autres la
plus répandue la plus connue étant yucca
mais elle est quand même challenge et
sur le fait qu'elle n'a pas d' approche
scientifique suffisamment par contre
elle signifie quand même que les
français sont en recherche
d'informations et d'indications donc
nous nous avons travaillé au sein de la
commission nationale de l'alimentation
du centre national de la consommation
pour essayer d'avoir des approche plus
scientifique c'est que tout le monde par
l'étiquetage étiquetage environnemental
étiquetage nutritionnel étiquetage rse
étiquetage
c'est très bien que les consommateurs
veulent savoir pourquoi il ne faut pas
les tromper
et là où il ya parfois des excès c'est
que par exemple le beurre et les
rillettes seront toujours classé rouge
ce qui est important c'est l'equilibre
de l'alimentation c'est à dire la part
de chaque produit dans l'alimentation et
les italiens en la matière ont fait un
peu mieux que nous je trouve en parlant
de portions il
non pas pour 100 g comment jamais 100 g
de beurre ni 100 g de riz est donc le
ramener à 100 grammes est trompeur faut
plutôt le ramener à c'est-à-dire la
ration c'est pas joli ça fait un peu
animal mais c'est ainsi qu'ils ont
appelé la portion consommer
habituellement donc oui la l'étiquetage
nutritionnel et très absent l'étiquetage
d'origine aussi le drapeau est utilisé à
tort et à travers
abusivement n'est abattu nés élevés a
battu en france ça veut dire quelque
chose
par contre transformer en france élaboré
en france avec le drapeau là nous sommes
en train de travailler pour justement
encadré et éviter de tromper le
consommateur c'est donc c'est une
question de bernard de saint maur des
fossés
christiane les nouvelles générations de
consommateurs sont conditionnés par le
végétarien le vegan et d'autres
restrictions alimentaires
une mode qu'on choisit de suivre ça se
respecte mais une idéologie dominante et
culpabilisante ça ce combat quel regard
portez-vous sur la récente volonté du
maire écologiste de l'union d'interdire
les repas avec de la viande dans les
cantines scolaires pas d'accord du tout
et j'ai des danses et les arguments
fallacieux qu'il avait employé sur le
thème c'est plus simple et c'est la
seule façon de nourrir tous les enfants
on sait très bien que ça faisait partie
de ces éléments de campagne d'ailleurs
il ya que la ville de lyon qui l'a fait
donc c'est un peu insultant pour les
cuisiniers les cantiniers les
cantinières de lyon ça veut dire qu'à
nice à lille ou à nantes ils sont
beaucoup plus rapides et il arrive à le
faire je pense que nous sommes dans un
pays où l'alimentation signifie quelque
chose et ce qui prévaut aussi c'est la
liberté de choix que l'on puisse choisir
sur d'alimentation c'est important
qu'elles soient pas imposées de façon
doctrinaire c'est essentiel aussi
aujourd'hui de très mauvais débat à
propos de la consommation de viande tous
les nutritionnistes vous diront qu'il
est important pour notre santé de
consommer de la viande
il ya un arrêté de
nos novembre 2011 qui dit qu'il faut
manger quatre repas de viande muscles
non h et sur une série de vingt repas
servis dans les cantines
donc c'est encadré et certains
voudraient passer à côté donc c'est très
qu'il ya aujourd'hui des demandes pour
consommer moins de viande mais mieux je
crois que interbev et les producteurs
l'ont compris ils ont entendu et
d'ailleurs dans les écoles quand on
regarde les menus il y à une diversité
de protéines animales
il ya aussi les oeufs le poisson mais il
faut ajouter aussi et ça c'est un
principe républicain auquel nous sommes
très attachés
c'est l'accès des enfants à une
alimentation équilibrée
on le sait tous et c'est un lieu commun
pour beaucoup d'enfants
le repas à la cantine c'est le seul
repas équilibré de la journée beaucoup
une petit déjeunent pas ce qui est
dramatique d'ailleurs parce qu'ils ont
le ventre vide dès 10h30 et nous savons
aussi que le soir n'est plus dans une
habitude de snacking de grignotage qui
n'est pas équilibré pour les enfants il
ya les aspects de savoir cuisiner maison
cuisine et c'est donc par rapport au
mois je respecte les gens qui veulent
devenir végétarien qu'il de l'imposent
part aux autres les conditions oui de
prosélytisme non c'est une question de
louis d'orvault quel regard portez vous
sur les mouvement antispéciste ce
dernier s'est récemment rendue coupable
d' actions violentes à l'encontre de nos
éleveurs je rajouterais un dernier
élément jeu j'ai déposé un amendement
dans la loi sécurité globale de façon à
faire augmenter les peines à trois ans
de prison et à 45000 euros d'amendé pour
tous ceux qui rentrent de façon
totalement inopinés interdite sur les
exploitations et dans des élevages
cet amendement on va passer la barre de
la commission je pense qu'il sera voté
en séance
ce qui vous permettra à la fnsea et tous
ceux qui défendent ce principe de
pouvoir s'en servir pourra enfin faire
aboutir le gouvernement qu il le promet
depuis deux ans et demi et qui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'a absolument rien fait
c'est traumatisant pour un agriculteur
de voir des personnes s'introduire dans
son exploitation dans son élevage
alors je lui c'est plus seulement les
élevages c'est aussi les personnes qui
travaillent dans leurs champs avec le
recevoir leur paie levée qui reçoivent
des gestes désagréables ou des insultes
cancer dans les élevages on sait qu'il
ya derrière des militants très
radicaliser ce ne sont pas des duels
fériste comme on les appelle des gens
qui défendent le bien-être animal
ce sont carrément des mouvements qui
défendent l'arrêt de l'élevage donc
c'est une idéologie une idéologie aussi
selon laquelle l'animal est une personne
idéologique on ne peut pas partager
parce que c'est un post humanisme qui
est contrairement contraire ce que nous
avons comme idée de la société de son
humanité
malheureusement ces mouvements se sont
poursuivis amplifié il y a eu des
agressions il ya eu des incendies a eu
des intrusions en plein jour alors
qu'avant cette époque tueur il y eut des
tags insultants il comprend y compris
par laurent deux élevages et gaz égal
nazisme
faisant référence à la période la plus
noire de notre histoire et les
agriculteurs quand vous leur en parler
c'est quelque chose qui les traumatise
parce que l'élevage fait partie de notre
culture nous sommes des omnivores
mangeant de la viande et ça se respecte
c'est nécessaire pour l'équilibré
alimentaire les élevages présente
également énormément davantage qu'est ce
qu'on ferait de nos 13 millions
d'hectares prairies si on n'est pas des
herbivores pour manger les prairies donc
l'élevage a toute sa place et ceux qui
font ça fond en plus porter un risque
très important au plan sanitaire
nous sommes en france à l'abri pour
l'instant de la fièvre porcine africaine
mais qui est passé des pays de l'est à
l'allemagne
nous avons des influences aviaire
régulièrement qui ont touché beaucoup le
grand sud ouest mais aussi l'est et la
noël et nous prenons mille précautions
pour assurer la biosécurité de nos
élevages
nous sommes contraints d investissements
parfois coûteux pour respecter vraiment
les normes sanitaires à vendredi dans
nos élevages et des personnes la nuit un
homme habillé norma ce qu'est qu'ils
soient les traînées dieu sait où avant
rentrer dans les élevages pour des
vidéos perturbe les animaux d'une part
il ya de l'écrasement beaucoup plus
quand ils rentrent avec des caméras
infrarouges et puis surtout faut porter
un lourd préjudice en terme de
sanitaires donc nous nous avons poussé
mais ça n'aboutit pas et je rejoins ce
que dit laurent duplomb il faut
absolument qu'on avance sur ce sujet
parce qu'il est une espèce d'impunité et
un crescendo 100 points sans punition
sans sanction suffisante
trop peu d'associations ont été dissous
de suisse suite à ces actions et je
pense qu'il faut les touchez là où ça
fait mal c'est à dire au porte monnaie
ce qu'a été le cas quand une procureure
a été courageuse dans le département de
l'eure mais il faut vraiment s'attaquer
à ce sujet parce que visitant récemment
une exploitation porcine dans finistère
il y avait un jeune stagiaire qui était
stagiaire donc en école d'agriculture
seule question qu'il est venu me poser
mais madame non mes parents en élevage
s'ils franchissent la barrière alors
qu'ils ont mis une barrière est ce que
mes parents peuvent porter notre siècle
dans les écoles d'agriculture
aujourd'hui c'est aussi un sujet qui
préoccupe la jeune génération que et
puis amplifiés un usage abusif du terme
lanceur de l'être ils ne sont pas
lanceurs d'alerté ils sont militants
violents radicaliser ils sont
délinquants puisqu'il rend dans des
lieux où ils n'ont pas à rentrer donc à
l'entrée des élevages
on met bâtiment sous protection
sanitaire interdiction de rentrer sans
l'autorisation des propriétaires on
incite les agriculteurs à fermer leurs
portes mais oui il faut vraiment arriver
à sanctionner plus dur et je le dis faut
même aussi probablement revoir le fait
qu'un certain nombre de ces associations
bénéficient de la maintenant fiscale
pour dons parce qu'elles sont reconnues
d'intérêt général franchement au stade
sont certaines c'est plus l'intérêt
général ce ça contribue à anéantir
l'élevage et les envies d'élevage d'un
certain nombre de personnes
donc sur ce sujet moi j'ai un discours
très ferme donc nous nous accompagnons
du mieux possible les victimes les
agriculteurs mais il faut arriver à
sanctionner plus ceux qui font ces
attaques sans nom j'ai une dernière
question pour pour christiane qui nous
vient d'arnaud de montesson alors nos
enfants sont de plus en plus
sensibilisés à l'écologie dans le cadre
scolaire
ne faudrait-il pas que l'éducation
nationale sensibilise également nos
enfants à l'agriculture et à ses
bienfaits pour l'environnement
oui alors il ya 15 ans et à 20 ans triés
pas nos déchets on n'avait pas une
poubelle carton plastique verre etc
aujourd'hui c'est passé dans les moeurs
donc oui nous avons changé notre société
a changé il ya maintenant on n'avait pas
de voiture qui s'arrêter au feu rouge
pour limiter la consommation d'énergie
donc évidemment que beaucoup
d'indicateurs d'opposer à dire que le
respect de la planète est nécessaire
mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup à dire
des contributions positives que
l'agriculture peut apporter justement
aux grands enjeux écologiques et autant
on n'empêchera pas les militants de
méditer et de pousser le trait est un
peu loin
autant nous agriculteurs et tous acteurs
avec nos partenaires de l'économique
nous avons besoin d'être plus bavard sur
ce que nous faisons c'est ce que font
nos interprofessions qu'ils s'agissent
d'interbev d'inaporc du cnj elle pour
expliquer bien aux plus jeunes avec des
supports très pédagogique et ludique
tous les apports de l'agriculture mais
les meilleurs ambassadeurs pour passer
le message reste encore les
scientifiques laissés derrière les
agriculteurs et nous devons prendre en
charge cette partie là on a peut-être
négligé cette réalité là aujourd'hui
avec les moyens vision on peut le faire
beaucoup plus je vais citer un exemple
très intéressant passion céréales qui a
mis en place une opération qui s'appelle
en direct de mon champ ou quelque chose
comme ça un agriculteur en début d'année
scolaire est en relation avec une classe
explique comment ils s'aiment semblait
pourquoi il met de l'engrais pourquoi
quand le blé présente des taches de
rouille et bien il intervient il traite
et c'est une pédagogie
deux situations loin de l'idéologie qui
permet d'expliquer on peut aussi partir
de l'alimentation sujet sur lequel les
jeunes et les enseignants sont très
sensibles qu'est ce qu'une alimentation
équilibrée
manger de tout d'où vient le lait d'où
vient la viande pourquoi c'est important
se comporter ainsi
et puis on a aujourd'hui la chance de
pouvoir le faire sur les réseaux sociaux
en direct sans filtre sans journalistes
parfois partisans souvent partisans
quand même maintenant et avec des a
priori important je participe et un
débat samedi matin avec un ancien
militant la confédération paysanne
devenue députée puis revenu militants
mais ce n'était pas celui de le lot de
l'aveyron c'était un autre bretagne et
qui n'avait que des messages négatifs
par rapport à l'agriculture
et franchement quand on voit aussi un
certain nombre de personnes issue de nos
rangs qui n'ont que des messages
négatifs qui parlent que c'était mieux
avant c'est la faute à ces si c'est ça
alors qu'il ya tellement à dire en
positive quand on voit tout ce que
l'agriculture peut apporter en termes
d'économie d'environnement d'emploi
d'aménagement du territoire dgt
équilibre nutritionnel
l'agriculture c'est une vraie chance
dans tous ces domaines pour la france et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut la défendre
telle qu'elle est mais elle fait l'objet
de beaucoup de militance de tous poils
de tout poil donc à nous avec notre
idéologie à nous d'être plus bavard pour
porter cette idée là et puis nous avons
la chance d'avoir une alimentation
brillantissime un reconnu comme
gastronomique partout dans le monde
quand on va à l'autre bout de la planète
des cours n'est ce qu'on dit qu'on est
français à la france l'alimentation le
champagne le cassoulet et puis bien
d'autres le brie de meaux voilà les
lentilles de haute loire les betteraves
le sylvaner et puis le gewert s'habille
très mineures et puis chez vous
qu'est-il et non le haricot de soissons
bah voila je connais mes classiques et
et le conte et puis voilà on peut
dérouler voilà la france c'est tout ça
et quand certains nous disent faut
changer de modèle faut changer de modèle
un slogan permanence qu'on entend
surtout accusant la fnsea d'avoir
prioriser un modèle puisque notre si la
france est belle et cultivé comme elle
est aujourd'hui c'est parce que les
agriculteurs sont présents partout et
que partout où il se trouve avec
imagination et obstination et pugnacité
en se levant tôt le matin comme
quelqu'un l'a dit ils ont trouvé là où
ils se trouvent des solutions pour
eux-mêmes donc haro sur le modèle unique
certains voudraient au pays des mille
fromages 1000 modèles et nous nous
défendons tous les modèles dans notre
organisation
merci merci christiane pour ce
formidable témoignage heures peut-être
juste une dernière question j'avais
ouvert tout à l'heure sur ce sujet sur à
la fois le le défi de l'alimentation de
l'alimentation mondiale
l'opposition de temps en temps que l'on
nous fait entre les lits circuit court
tu parlais de modèles en zahia pas un
seul modèle le circuit court est un
modèle mais ça ne peut pas se résumer à
cela je pense qu'il est important de
montrer que l'agriculture est ce qu'elle
est parce que justement elle est diverse
parce que on a besoin de produits
transformés
élaborer et qu'on ne peut pas répondre à
toutes les demandes part du seul circuit
court et puis aussi peut-être un mot en
même temps sur un débat qui revient
souvent sur lequel on a interrogé sur
aujourd'hui la réponse que l'agriculture
peut apporter en matière d'environnement
je pense aux carburants je le dis en
regardant notre de nos sénateurs pire qu
père ce qui est cliquée larmes
aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de concurrence entre la
capacité à produire de l'énergie et
celle à produire de l'alimentation de la
même façon que l'agriculture aussi le
plus formidable pièges à carbone qui
puisse exister
je veux pas te relancer sur un sujet non
mais j'essaie de rassembler pourquoi on
zoome les circuits courts
il ya vingt ans les français n'étaient
pas près autant qu'aujourd'hui à
consommer en circuit court
ils étaient tous à se ruer vers les
supermarchés qui représente encore
aujourd'hui je crois que vous avez
michel edouard leclerc après 75 % des
courses faites par les français 75%
donc ça veut dire que c'est quand même
le lieu où majoritairement les français
vont chercher leur alimentation pour
différentes raisons mais le prix est un
des éléments puis la diversité de choix
21% des agriculteurs pratiquent la vente
directe c'est à dire qu'il y en a plus
qu'il n'ya jamais eu 30 % font des
produits sous signes officiels de
qualité donc on a quand même une très
grande diversité est aussi cette
diversité qualitative alors jamais les
circuits courts de permettront de
satisfaire la totalité des demandes
alimentaire tout comme jamais
l'agriculture biologique permettra
d'offrir à tout le monde
l'alimentation accessible tout comme il
n'est pas possible de produire sans
pesticide a fait il ya des lieux communs
qu'il faut répéter comme ça et là
personne de la profession paysanne la
semaine dernière disait on est capable
sous cinq ans de produits avec zéro
pesticide
ce à quoi un chercheur de l'inra
enseignants-chercheurs répondu non sous
cinq ans on n'y arrivera pas mais quand
ce sont des agriculteurs qui le dit ça
nuit beaucoup là à la halle à la
crédibilité et à ce que les français
peuvent entendre biocarburants alors je
cite souvent alors je disais il ya
trente ans mais ça fait plus que ça
pierre maintenant la des casseurs
d'affaires 40 45 ans ouest hier matin et
les biocarburants alors qu'ils sont
souvent décriés par les biocarburants de
première génération qu'il faudrait
mettre à la poubelle on parle de
génération avancée et c'est dans notre
élevage de porcs dont nous utilisons 100
% tourteau de colza
heureusement qu'il y a des biocarburants
de première génération qui permettent à
côté des carburants d'avoir des
coproduits les tourteaux sur toute la
façade atlantique on en produit et c'est
une chance nous permet d'être dans un
cahier des charges tourteau de colza etc
etc
alors il ya eu à l'époque les grincheux
et vous avez tenu bon il y a encore
aujourd'hui les grincheux plus bavard
plus vite
plus porté par certains courants il faut
lutter pour maintenir mais il ya des
engagements de la france dans les
sommets internationaux pour tenir un
engagement de d'énergie verte dans le
bouquet énergétique
nous devons arriver à 30% d'énergie
verte et il faut à la fois des
biocarburants du photovoltaïque d eau
l'éolien tout ce que l'agriculture sait
faire et moi j'ai plaisir à dire et je
suis très fier de dire c'est
l'agriculture qui vais redire à
l'industrie nous avons les solutions ça
c'est l'agriculture ça c'est la vie
culture c'est l'eau ça s'il ya du bois
c'est l'agriculture aussi il y en a et c
les chaises demain seront en plastique
végétal nos stylos etc à nos emballages
sire que le végétal renouvelables c'est
la source inépuisable pour justement
atteindre ses objectifs et je préfère ça
que des suppressions drastique de sacs
plastiques comme l'avait brandi brune
poirson nous obligeant à les acheter nos
pommes par trois c'est ce qu'on peut
porter dans la main quoi donc je pense
qu'il faut faire confiance aussi à la
recherche il y a dans l'aube il en
champagne des grands pôles de
compétitivité et de recherche
agronomique qui recherchent justement
sur tout ce qui est chimique verte et
nous en avons besoin donc oui vraiment
c'est l'agriculture qui vais redire à
l'industrie alors le vert dira aussi
avec la capture carbone parce que ici ça
capte pas de carbone dans la rue non
plus mais dans nos champs nos prêts nos
forêts on capte du carbone et à ceux qui
font la chasse aux maïs en disant que
c'est la plante de tous les défauts un
hectare de maïs capte deux fois plus de
carbone qu'une fourcade hectares de
forêt et donc nos cultures nos herbages
capte du carbone et noé capte du carbone
et dans mon département on a mis en
place des contrats de prestations pour
service environnemental avec la poste la
poste à la flotte automobile la plus
importante pour livrer le courrier au
dernier kilomètre
ils ont besoin de compenser pour leurs
airs et ce aussi et bien on a
contractualisé et les agriculteurs
éleveurs du maine et loire qui
entretiennent leur et avec un cahier des
charges durable touche d un paiement du
carbone capté par la poste
l'entreprise la poste qui les rémunèrent
et certaines 3000 4000 euros pour
entretenir leur et dans un cahier des
charges du rap donc déjà aujourd'hui on
est capable de faire ces contrats à la
fnsea on a créé un outil on a travaillé
dix ans pour faire ce concept
et ça s'appelle et peter et peter comme
épicentre tout part de la terre et peter
pour justement faire ces marchés là nous
avons compensé l'année dernière c'est la
même couleur bleue le carbone émis par
l'aref le rassemblement des entreprises
françaises du medef et j'irai le 1er
avril avec geoffroy roux de bézieux dans
la marne planter une haie pour enfin
voir une haie plantée on veillait à la
sainte catherine pascal à sainte
catherine tout arbre prend racine
malheureusement on était confiné on est
resté confiné en ai parlé mais il faut
compenser avec des entreprises
françaises
ça me faisait mal au coeur de voir qui
compensait en indonésie nous avons fait
une proposition deuxième année nous
sommes retenus et donc trente six qui
veulent tonnes équivalent co2 compensées
avec 9 km de haies plantées dans la
marne
la belle région que philippe mangin
connais très bien voilà ce qu'on peut
faire aussi pour rendre mon et yable ses
services rendus jusque là gratuitement
mais qui ensuite valeur aujourd'hui et
qui vont redorer le blason de
l'agriculture également